I have actually this is a simple have a
little bit of trouble with because I
actually learned my astronomy in America
I was a PhD student in America and when
I returned for a long time I had to
catch myself not call it Z it was very
strange because I thought of the letter
as Zed but this astronomical use of it I
always thought was Z rather than Zed
anyway Zed is the symbol that
astronomers used for measuring redshift
so it was a big deal in astronomy I
guess at the beginning it started that
maybe the beginning of the 20th century
people started looking at the light from
galaxies out there and this was actually
before they were known to be galaxies so
they were referred to as nebulae and
people started looking at the light from
these nebulae and found that they were
all red shifted which means in this
interpretation of you know where this
redshift comes from it means they were
running away from us so in fact it's
even a few objects that have blue shifts
there are things that are actually
coming towards us rather than going away
from us one of the most interesting
things that actually has a blue shift is
the end Amida galaxies so the nearest
big galaxy to the Milky Way the
Andromeda galaxy actually as a blue
shift rather than a red shift that means
it's piling towards the Milky Way and in
fact in about 3 or 4 billion years is
going to be a big collision the two
galaxies are actually in a crash into
each other so by measuring the redshift
or in this case the blue shift you can
actually figure out when that collision
is going to happen what's going to
happen then what would that look like
and be like from our perspective it's
going to be remarkably dull have to say
because the thing you need to remember
about galaxies is they're almost
entirely empty space if you built a
scale model on the Milky Way and you
made the Sun the size of a marble then
the next nearest star that the next
nearest marble would be about 50 miles
away so basically galaxies really are
mostly empty space so if you take one
load of empty space in another load of
empty space and crash them into each
other they kind of just passed straight
through each other but what does happen
of course is that the pull of gravity of
the Milky Way on Andromeda is going to
do terrible things to Andromeda's kind
of arrangement and the same thing the
other way around to any star at all hit
each other
very rarely if you do the calculation to
try and figure out because they're
mostly empty space they mostly just miss
each other and you'll probably find in a
conclusion like that where you've got 10
billion stars on the one hand and 10
billion stars on the other hand most
maybe one of them will smash into one
other one so this really is really not a
particularly common event
so it's very much akin to the kind of
Doppler shift that everyone's familiar
with you know when a fire engine or
police car goes past you and the siren
one of the things coming towards you
it's slightly higher pitched and the
things going away from you the picture
slightly lower and so the pitch changes
depending on the relative motion of
these two things so that's the the
Doppler shift in sound the same thing
happens with light the way I like to
think about it is that the universe is
expanded so let's say this is the
universe at an early stage maybe you
know 10 billion years ago the universe
is continually expanding remember and
this is a photon of light and that's the
wavelength of the photon so it's quite a
short wavelength so that means is quite
a blue photon of light then universe
expands as we know so let's expand the
universe so the universe is expanding
significantly now and you can see the
wavelength of the light is significantly
longer and that means it's a redder
photon of light and that's what gives
you the redshift it's C stretching the
expansion of space-time as a universe
expands and so and that's one of the
neat things about the redshift by
measuring the redshift you not only know
the distance to this galaxy using
Hubble's law which I know there's
another video about but you're also
looking very far back in time how did
you know that our redshift and how do
you know that it didn't happen to be
more red so what you actually look at is
you don't look at just the general life
and things you what you say is
absolutely true if you just see a bunch
of red light you say well maybe it's
just something that's red perfectly
reasonable to do but conveniently nature
kind of provides us with little markers
in in the spectrum so that if you
actually break the light from a star up
into its constituent color so you put a
prism or something and break the light
up you do indeed see the colors of the
rainbow but superimposed on those colors
of the rainbow you see little dark lines
and each of those little dark lines is
where some element in the atmosphere of
the star is absorbing light at a very
specific wavelength and so those provide
nice little markers that are very
specific wavelengths so we can do the
experiment in the laboratory and measure
exactly the wavelength they're supposed
to be at
and then you go and make the same
measurement on a style and you find that
the little dark band due to absorption
is it a different wavelength so you can
see that it shifted towards the red so
this was from a long exposure on a
tweeter telescope in Chile of one of the
faint galaxies in here couldn't tell you
which one this is four thousand
angstroms that would look blue to your
eyes this is about seven or eight
thousand a little red to your eyes so
this is an optical spectrum but if you
were closer to that galaxy all of these
lines would be shifted and compressed
over to the blue part of the spectrum so
this spectrum has stretched basically as
the universe is expanded and then we
measured it with our TAS coat and we can
determine how far away it is so this is
one of those strange quantities that
actually is completely dimensionless as
long as you use the same units and do
everything consistently you end up with
a dimensionless number so the redshift
is actually defined such that if you
have one of these little dark absorption
lines so you have some hydrogen which is
absorbing at a particular wavelength and
you can make that measurement in the
laboratory you measure its wavelength to
be a certain number of nanometers or
angstroms or any unit you want to
measure it in and then you measure the
same thing in a star you'll find it a
different wavelength so you can measure
the difference between those numbers how
much the wavelength has changed and then
you just divide that by the wavelength
you started with and because you're
dividing something in nanometers are
changing wavelength by something else in
nanometers and the wavelength you
started with you just end up with a
number and then it doesn't matter
whether you measure that may theorem
until nanometers or furlongs or whatever
you want any unit of length you like
you'll always end up with the same
redshift I'm leading a project right now
where we can detect galaxies to redshift
of 6 which means the light stretched by
a factor of seven so what does that mean
in terms of the evolution of the
universe the light left those objects
over 12 billion years ago it's actually
it's mind-boggling when you think about
it I mean we're studying galaxies in the
universe as indan see we could produce
images of these galaxies study their
characteristics understand what elements
are present and we're seeing them before
the earth itself was even formed so this
is a project that was talking about
we've used many hundreds of nights of
telescope time on a large telescope in
Hawaii the UK infrared telescope to try
and understand galaxies in the very year
universe so using an infrared telescope
precisely because of this redshift
effect if you study a galaxy the very
early universe the light has been
stretched by such an extent that the
normal optical light that most stars
produce has been stretched into the
infrared so up until fairly recently our
understanding of the very distant
universe was very biased because we used
optical telescopes all the optical
images were all used to from Hubble and
so on when you're looking at the very
distant universe you only see a tiny
fraction of what's going on out there so
what we're seeing here is an image that
we produce by combining data from an
optical telescope in Hawaii with an
infrared telescope so anything that
looks blue there you would be able to
see with an optical telescope or if you
like you know your eyes are sensitive to
that light anything that looks red for
example these red blobs here those would
be completely invisible to an optical
telescope even to the Hubble Space
Telescope
so as we pan across this image you see
that there are galaxies of all different
colors here's a very bright blue star in
our own galaxy it's so bright this
produces bleeding effect on the CCD
camera that's not real it's just because
it's so bright the electrons spill over
on the detector so that's kind of a star
in the foreground that's ruined your
photo absolutely yeah they're a real
pain they get in a way what we're really
interested in all the blobs that you see
behind so most of the things you can see
in this image are galaxies so here's a
particularly beautiful blue spiral a
relatively nearby spiral actually I'm
not particularly interested in that one
where I'm interested in are the fainter
blobs in the background those faint red
dots that you can maybe just see
invisible with an optical telescope we
now know from studying their redshift
that those are galaxies that wisk that
whose lights left the objects more than
10 11 12 billion years ago